Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow
of death, I will not fear for you are with me.
You are my light and my salvation.
You restore me and lead me for your glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
Yeah, yeah.
Wow. So, uh, sometimes it's really interesting
how the sovereignty of God works things out in our lives.
And all week I've been studying Psalm 72 in preparation
for today as we've been just taking one by one as we go
through the Psalms and,
and what it shows us is a picture of an ideal king
of what Israel's king was supposed to
be like supposed to do.
But really in the end it shows us that every one
of those kings fell short.
And so what it then shifted into was that it was
to point them and point us to the true king,
to the Messiah, the king of Israel, Jesus.
But then as I watched the events of last night unfold
and I sat there pondering why God had chosen to put us
in Psalm 72 this week in light
of the political mess we're facing.
And I wrestled with whether I should just throw the whole
thing out and do something different
or should I like preach it
as is if nothing ever happened last night
or should I just watch what God wants to do to tweak it?
Well, so I, I sent a message to the elders
and we began praying and just considering,
okay, what do we do with this?
Throughout the evening began praying and considering and,
and so as we did that it was, it was like God's
leading was giving confidence that this is
where God wants us to be
in Psalm 72 talking about the ideal Messiah king.
And it doesn't minimize what's happened.
It's not to be insensitive to loss and pain
or even uncertainty about the future of our nation
or how things are gonna work out politically.
It's not to minimize any of that,
but it's to point to what is solid
and to point to what is eternal in the end.
How no earthly leader can fulfill this.
Yes, we'll see that.
But also it's gonna lead us, I believe, to show us
how we should respond, how we should
handle the uncertainty
and the fear that we might feel at times.
So again, let's pray, asking God for help in that Lord, I
has, you've already seen needy
and grateful for prayers of your saints, your people.
But Lord we need you to speak to us through your word.
Holy Spirit, use your word to deeply affect us,
to teach us as Psalm 86 11.
Teach us your way, oh God,
that we may walk in your truth, unite
our hearts to fear your name,
to have a soul focus on you above all else.
Teach us Lord, we need you. Thank you.
In Jesus' name. Amen.
Then so if you're not already there, go ahead
and take your copy of God's word.
Turn with me to Psalm 72.
Um, I did spend a couple hours last night tweaking this
sermon and so I'm praying that being sensitive
to God's spirit is what he wants us
to do today as we've already seen.
But as we look at Psalm 72,
just look at the very last verse.
First, provide some context on this psalm
and really the entire journey we've taken over the last five
years as we've walked through the Psalms to this point.
Look at verse 20. It says, the prayers of David, the son
of Jesse are ended.
Now, you might not realize this,
but the entire, what we call the book
of the Psalms 150 Psalms
is really arranged into five books as you look right
below verse 20 and it says Book three in big
letters probably doesn't it?
And these five books in the Psalms
loosely tell the story of Israel, like books one
and two, you've got from Psalm one
through here in Psalm 72 are primarily by David,
this victorious king and the development of the kingdom.
And then you get to Psalm 73 shifts into book three.
Next week it, it gets pretty dark
because what it talks about is the kings
and the kingdom falling and the sanctuary being destroyed.
And then you get into book four,
it talks primarily about the exile of Israel
and then book five is the restoration.
So you can kind of trace the history
of Israel throughout the Book of Psalms.
And yet what we've seen so far, books one
and two are primarily the prayers of David,
the victorious king.
We'll see more from David a few times in three, four
and five, but but primarily David yet look at the heading
of Psalm 72.
What does it say? It says of Solomon.
Now we aren't sure if Solomon wrote this himself
or maybe someone else wrote it for him.
Could have been his dad. David wrote this for Solomon,
yet it works beyond Solomon at the same time.
See this, this is to Solomon in some sense,
but it's also to future kings
after him as well as to the nations
because it, it works beyond just one person.
We'll see it very clearly.
Look at it with me and just imagine this scene like
Solomon's being cor, the coronation of Solomon as the king.
Just imagine that this is being read at his
or anyone else's coronation
and listen with the mind to see what it is pointing us
to give the king your justice.
Oh God, may your righteousness to the royal Son.
May he judge your people with righteousness
and your poor with justice.
Let the mountains bear prosperity for the people,
the hills in righteousness.
May he defend the cause of the poor of the people.
Give deliverance to the chil children of the needy
and crush the oppressor.
May he endure or may they fear you while the sun endures
as long as the moon throughout all generations.
May he be like rain that falls on the moon grass like
showers that water the earth in his days.
May the righteous flourish and peace abound
till the moon be no more.
May he have dominion from sea to sea,
from the river to the ends of the earth.
May desert tribes bow down before him
and his enemies lick the dust.
May the kings of Tarshish
and of the coastlands render him tribute.
May the kings of Sheba and Siba bring gifts.
May all kings fall down before him
and all nations serve him
for he delivers the needy when he calls the poor
and him who has no helper.
He has pity on the weak and the needy
and saves the lives of the needy
from oppression and violence.
He redeems their life. Precious is their blood in his sight.
Long may he live. May gold of Sheba be given to him.
May prayer be made for him continually
and blessings invoked for him all the day.
May there be abundance of grain in the
land on the tops of the mountains.
May it wave, may its fruit.
Be like Lebanon and may people blossom in the cities like
the grass of the field.
May his name endure forever, his fame continue
as long as the sun.
May people be blessed in him. All nations call him blessed.
Blessed be the Lord the God of Israel
who alone does wondrous things,
blessed be his glorious name forever.
May the whole earth be filled with his glory. Amen and amen.
Amen. And the prayers of David, the son of Jesse
Are ended.
So like I said before, this psalm
was setting out the parameters of
what we would call the ideal Davidic king.
If you remember your history,
God made a covenant with King David.
This is second Samuel chapter seven, where one
of David's sons would sit on the throne of Israel forever.
That this Psalm 72 was then what
that king was supposed to be like.
This is what they were supposed to live like and act like.
By the way, this Psalm sets us up nicely
for our study in First Samuel beginning in August
as we talk about how that kingship even developed.
But again, this psalm itself is talking about what kind
of king David's son, Solomon
and beyond was to be like
how was his reign supposed to be characterized?
Well, a commentator was, was putting this together in a,
in a really clear way.
And so I'm gonna follow his thoughts here,
but he first said this king was to be just
and righteous David's son.
The king was to be just
and righteous verses one and two.
Again, give the king your justice.
Oh God, may your and your righteousness to the royal Son.
May he judge your people with righteousness
and you're poor with justice.
So this king, the primary evidence of his justice
and righteousness for the people was in his concern
for the poor, concern for the needy, concern
for the oppressed, the defenseless, the weak.
How did he handle those people that wealth
and power did not supersede humanity, that he cared
for all people equally.
Verse four, may he defend the cause of the poor
of the people give deliverance to the children of the need.
He crushed the oppressor.
Verse 12, he delivers the needy when he calls the poor in
him who has no helper.
Verse 13, he has pity on the weak.
The needy saves the lives of the needy.
Verse 14, from oppression
and violence, he redeems their life.
Precious is their blood in his sight.
The ideal Davidic king was to be full of compassion,
to see the lives of the weak in his kingdom as precious
to him, not as castoffs, but as precious
because that's the way God is towards us.
That's the way the king was to be to his kingdom.
In fact, it's the way we're supposed
to be as well, isn't it?
So the king was to be just and righteous.
Next we find the king's reign was to be peaceful.
His reign was to be characterized as peaceful.
That's the word in verse three
and verse seven, character, uh, translated
as prosperity and peace.
It's the Hebrew word shalom.
It's translated prosperity and peace. It means peace.
Yes, but it's mean. It means more than that.
It means wellbeing, it means wholeness.
It means that you have enough.
It means that you're able to say with timon,
ooba, haku, matata.
Now that's not a Hebrew phrase
that we're gonna have to translate, right?
That's some other language that means no worries,
that's shalom, that's peace.
It means you don't have anything to worry about.
But back in the Old Testament,
this word shalom was expressed often by abundant crops,
grass for the sheep, fruit trees that flourished.
You see it in verse three.
Let the mountains bear prosperity shalom for the people
like you see it in verse seven.
In his days, may the righteous flourish
and peace abound till the moon be no more.
That's the shalom. He's talking about this.
This rain was to be characterized by peace.
And in an agricultural setting like that, they had
to have rain from the clouds for that to happen, right?
That's why. Look at verse six, the king's rain, R-E-G-I-G-N.
His rain was to be compared to rain. RAIN.
That falls from the sky.
Verse six, may he the king be like rain
that falls on the moan grass like showers
that water the earth, the king's reign, his rule was
to bring shalom to the people,
but not just for the people of Israel.
If you saw in Psalm 72, the ideal Davidic king's reign was
to be worldwide as well.
This was to be a worldwide kingdom.
Verse eight, may he have dominion from sea to sea
and from the river the Euphrates to the ends
of the earth.
That was the entire known world at the time.
All of it. And then you add verses nine through 11,
may desert tribes bow down before him.
His enemies lick the dust.
May the kings of Tarshish weigh at the end of the sea
of the coastlands, render him tribute.
May the kings of Sheba
and Siba, those were from North Africa, bring gifts.
May all kings fall down before him.
All nations serve this just
and righteous king.
This psalm asked God to sow, extend the rule of the king
that all nations would submit to his rule and reign
and thereby receive the blessings of God's kingdom
through the king supposed to be worldwide.
Remember that promise was made actually back in Genesis 12
to Abraham that all the families
of the earth would be blessed through him.
How's that gonna play out through the Davidic King?
Verse 17, may his name endure forever.
His fame continue as long as the son.
May people check this out.
May people be blessed in him
and all nations call him blessed.
Is that not Genesis 12?
So it's to be worldwide.
It's also we learn here to be long, the king's reign was
to be long verse
15, long may he live the request
that this king would live a long time.
Verse 17, may his name endure forever
and a long reign for this king would be a good thing if he's
bringing shalom and prosperity
and peace to all people, all nations, right?
That would mean we want him to stay in power longer.
It's a long supposed to be a long rule.
Yet here's what we can't forget.
Did you notice all these requests
and all the benefits have a source?
This Davidic King's reign was to be
dependent if it was gonna work at all.
His reign was to be
dependent, dependent on what?
On his own strength, on his own abilities,
on his own nation's resources
that he's got everything he has.
No, he's depe. He's to be dependent on the divine king.
What does verse one start with?
A request that God would give justice
and righteousness to the king.
The whole thing is a prayer for the king.
And on behalf of the king God, do this.
God make this happen as wealthy
and as powerful as every Davidic king would be in Israel
and eventually in Judah,
they were still fully dependent on God for everything,
which is why I believe verses 18 and 19 are included here.
Because here's another aspect
of the ideal Davidic king's reign.
It was to be doxological.
It's a long word doxological.
It means worshipful
that his reign was to lead people to worship God.
Because look at verses 18
and 19 again, it says, blessed be the Lord Yahweh,
the God of Israel, who alone does wondrous things,
blessed be his glorious name forever.
May the whole earth be filled with his glory. Amen.
Let it be and let it be.
He says, So when you look at this psalm, you think
of an earthly king living this out.
They would be worthy of honor. They'd be worthy of praise.
Yes, but I've
heard it said so well.
The ultimate praise is directed to the ultimate source
of the king's just and righteous reign.
The ultimate praise is not to that king.
The ultimate praise is to Yahweh, who's the source
of everything that king has.
In fact, that was again one of the most primary jobs
for the king of Israel, was to point his people to Yahweh,
to remind them of God's word, to uphold proper ways
of worship and sacrifice in life.
Like this is how life should work, this is
how God should be worshiped.
They were supposed to do that which would lead to worship
and blessing and glory being given
to God throughout the whole earth forever and ever.
That was the intention for every
King.
And so this psalm paints a beautiful picture of
what the ideal Davidic King should be like.
And as the heading suggests, Solomon was the first,
I Mean, just think of life, that life
and reign of Solomon.
Solomon was just and righteous.
He was the wisest man who ever lived.
He was able to discern incredibly difficult, difficult cases
and he readily provided for the poor in the land.
He led the most peaceful
and prosperous era of shalom in Israel's history.
His reach was worldwide. In fact, the Queen of Sheba.
Remember we saw Sheba a couple times here in Psalm 72,
the Queen of Sheba in Ethiopia heard about Solomon's wealth
and wisdom and she came traveling, bringing gifts.
Solomon was also very dependent on the Lord
at the beginning of his reign.
This is what one Kings three records, him praying
to God, Solomon prays.
Now, Lord God, you have made your servant king in place
of David, my father, although I'm
but a little child, I do not know how to go out or come in.
And your servant is in the midst
of your people whom you've chosen a great people too many
to be numbered or counted for multitude.
Give your servant therefore an understanding mind
to govern your people that I may discern between good
and evil for who is able to to govern this,
your great people.
And God answered his prayer by giving him abundant wisdom.
The wisest man who ever's lived and abundant wealth
because he didn't ask for it.
He asked for wisdom and God blessed him beyond measure.
And finally, Solomon's reign was doxological.
His father, David wanted to,
but he could never build God's temple
because of all of his experiences at war.
He had to clear the land of all the enemies of God.
And so David couldn't do it. But Solomon finally did.
Solomon built God's house
and at its dedication, he led the people in many sacrifices
and praises and blessings to God.
It was a rich worship experience. And he kept doing that.
He kept doing that.
Yet,
yet
as great as one kings, one
through 10 shows us it was for Solomon.
As great as his wisdom was, as great as his wealth was
as prosperous as the nation was.
One kings one through 10 shows us the incredible picture of
what it looked like when solemn was at the peak.
In the very next chapter, we see this
one Kings 11 verse one.
Now, king Solomon loved many foreign women.
See, God had earlier warned his people not
to intermarry with those who worship other gods.
Not because he didn't love the nations, it was
because he knew that his people's hearts would be stolen
away from worshiping him.
Yet verse two, Solomon clung to these in love,
700 of them.
And what do we read next?
And his wives turned away, his heart,
he even built, remember the guy who built the temple
even travels around the country,
begin building shrines to all these false
Gods That his wives were worshiping.
And immediately we see God was angry with Solomon, raises up
the enemy within his walls, tell Solomon,
the kingdom's gonna soon break apart.
All the prosperity and honor that you had
before is soon going to be gone.
And so here's the tragic point.
Even Solomon in all his glory did not live up
to fell far short of the ideal Davidic king.
Picture we see in Psalm 72,
Solomon was as close as Israel ever got
to this actually happening.
And yet he failed.
You trace the story of Solomon's life.
Even we saw it right there. He did
not live a righteous life.
Strife and battles.
No more shalom strife and war reentered the land.
They lost influence globally.
He failed to depend on God and worship God alone
and he eventually died.
But it wasn't only Solomon,
even though Psalm 72 portrays this ideal king,
how they were supposed to live each successive king
after Solomon seemed to get progressively worse.
Now, there are glimpses at times of reforms
that kings would try to bring back to Psalm 72 in Judah.
But ultimately what we see is failure
after failure of even this Davidic line of kings.
That means there was something more going on in
Psalm 72, right?
Something deeper.
Well over time what Psalm 72 turned into as the people
of Israel saw none of our kings are gonna live this out.
What it turned into was then their desire
for a perfect king.
It it turned into a prayer for the coming
of the anointed king, the Messiah.
They started to read it with with eyes that began
to look forward instead of just like, is this the guy?
Is this the guy They were looking forward
to, something to come.
Now they were looking for a good
and righteous king here,
but there was this understanding that only a fully divine
as well as fully human king could actually live up
to this ideal right as every king comes
to the throne they were supposed to.
And it was right to pursue Psalm 72 for the people to desire
that from their leader.
But it was also ultimately their hope could only be
fulfilled in this Messiah king who's coming.
They saw the weakness, they saw the failure,
and this was something they needed in the future.
That led me to think of things last night
that I saw a pastor friend post.
That we look around at all the anger and hatred and violence
and division plaguing our nation and our world
and we ask, okay, so what's the answer like?
Like what is the answer to the seeds
that Satan plants of discord
and distrust where we begin to see fellow image bearers
of God not as humans,
but as obstacles to what we feel like we want and need.
What is the answer? I think
that's the wrong question.
What? What is the answer
to us viewing those things as justifiable?
The anger, the discord, the violence.
We see that as justifiable in our own minds,
but we can't help but think it's just abhorrent
whenever they on the other side would do it to us.
What is the answer? I think that's the wrong question.
I think to get to the root, we need
to ask who is the answer?
Because what this is pointing to is that there's nothing
inherent in what.
That's the answer. It's the who.
That's the answer
and the who.
That's the answer is not whichever
political leader you favor.
It's not a military leader.
It's not a a philosophical leader.
It's not an education reformer.
Because the reality of every single one of those people is
that they all need a savior too.
The answer has been Jesus still is Jesus
and will always be Jesus.
See, that's the truth
that I believe Psalm 72 ultimately shows us church
that Christ did
and will ultimately fulfill this ideal
that he fully met it
and he will fully meet it forever and ever.
He is this ideal, the only one who
ultimately fulfills this picture of the ideal king. That's
Right.
Watch this. Think of
how the magi from far east lands came
to his birth and what did they bring?
Gold and frankincense and mer.
These kings from afar brought him gifts.
Think of how Christ as he lived his life was filled
with the justice of God as he treated the poor fairly.
He rescued children of the needy. He had pity on the weak.
He saw them as precious.
Think of how he lived out a perfectly righteous life
by never sinning one time.
Think of how he fully depended on his father in every scene
of his life at every moment of his life. That's
Right.
And so we can already see glimpses of
how Christ is the one who fulfills this,
but there's also so much of Psalm 72 that's yet
to be fulfilled, right?
Like this is the principle we call already,
but not yet that the kingdom of God has come in Christ,
but it's not yet finally fulfilled completely.
Yet we know it's here.
We see glimpses of it, but it's not yet final.
So just think again here. Let me, let me show you this.
Think of the triumphal entry.
John 1215 it.
It quotes a prophecy from Zechariah chapter nine.
This is what we see said of Jesus
as he's writing in on a donkey into the city of Jerusalem.
People are rejoicing him.
They're quoting this Zechariah nine
rejoice greatly daughter of Zion.
Shout aloud, daughter of Jerusalem.
Behold your king is coming to you righteous,
having salvation.
Is he humble and mounted on a donkey, on a cult,
the full of a donkey.
But listen to this next verse.
I will cut off the chariot from Ephraim
and the warhorse from Jerusalem.
The battle bow shall be cut off.
He shall speak peace shalom to the nations.
His rule shall be from sea to sea
and from the river to the ends of the earth.
Does that sound familiar? Who is that talking about?
Which means? Who is Psalm 72 talking about?
Is talking about the Messiah Jesus And
what he's bringing it said is global shalom.
Or think about how the crowd, a few verses later, John 1234,
they said the Christ, they knew it.
The Christ remains forever.
They understood that a son
of David would sit on the throne forever.
How did they even come up with that?
Psalm 72, may his name endure forever.
What are they getting that from at this son of David?
The eternal one has to be able to live forever.
Think of how Isaiah 11 talks about the root of Jesse,
the son of David, the Messiah as the one
to whom the nations will come
and inquire to worldwide reign.
See, this is the main point of all this today.
It's not to make us sad about the fact
that Solomon didn't fulfill this.
It's to make us rejoicing that we can look forward as well
as they did to the day when our king Jesus will come back
again when we see the mountains of the new heavens
and the new earth will bear perfect prosperity
for all of God's people.
This ideal king will reign in refreshing
and life-giving ways to all nations who will be blessed
through him and will bring him praise.
And so we can pray this legitimately right?
Come quickly Lord Jesus as Revelation 22,
the very last book right
before you get to the maps in your Bible,
the very last phrase, come quickly, Lord Jesus, we can pray
that because this is what he's going to bring us.
So what do we do until then?
What do we do? Until then?
Let's not get caught up
in placing our hope in a faulty king or a faulty government.
It Our true
king, we see him.
We know who he is. We know where he is coming.
Whether you're Republican or Democrat
or independent or I don't care.
Whatever you are, let's place our
hope in the true king, the ideal king,
the perfect king
who will satisfy everything we've ever longed for.
And as we do that, because it's already
but not yet, as we do place our hope in that king,
what did Jesus say to pray?
God, your kingdom come on earth as it is in heaven.
So the king's coming later.
He's already here, but he's coming back later
to bring his kingdom in full.
But now your kingdom come on earth now
as it is in heaven now.
So what we are to do in light of our king is
to bring his kingdom to bear on earth as it is in heaven.
That we are ambassadors of the king.
We are to be lights in the darkness.
We are to shine bright so that our
good works would give glory to our father who is in heaven.
We are to pray for all people.
We are to forgive as we've been forgiven.
We are to season our words with grace.
We are to love even our enemies.
We are to seek wisdom from God's word.
We are to vote our whole lives to this Christ, his worship.
We are to share the gospel with all nations.
We are to rejoice in the Lord always.
We are to stand firm in the full armor of God.
We are to remember, we don't fight against flesh and blood.
We fight against the powers and
and principalities of this dark age and ultimately church.
We are to live with full assurance
that this victory has already been won.
That no matter, no matter what the enemy may try, no matter
what the world may say, there is a grave outside
of Jerusalem that's been empty for 2000 years
and there is a throne in heaven
that is fully eternally occupied
forever and ever. That's right.
That's right. So what do we do?
We look to the lambs. That's right.
The lamb who is seated on the throne above all things.
We look to the lamb, we pray, we grieve, we work
absolutely while we are here.
But we are to never lose this perspective, to never forget
that this Christ is our ideal king.
He's the one who fulfills it all on our behalf.
He's the one we can trust everything to in our lives today.